bell a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono famigie
risiamo di nuovo su slay underwood
eravamo rimasti che erano entrati in
questa casa con una botta di culo che
veramente non mi ricapiterà mai più
ho provato ad aprire una porta a caso
con la chiave c'avevo lo svenderà
attaccato e sono riuscito ad entrare va
beh
eravamo rimasti qua c'è gran bel dipinto
che secondo me era lo slider quando
aveva ancora la faccia eccesso
ticchettio che non miri nomi assicura
per niente magari a una bomba strano
all'orologio non ha non a minuti o le
lancette a è vero un'ora le lancette voi
chi se ne frega ma ce lo slider che ti
segue tutti preoccupi e l'orologio non
ha le lancette ma cosa ti sei fumato
perfetto qua c'è una nuova ragazzi se
volete leggerla stoppato il video perché
io non la leggo bel bei fiori bei fiori
si sono nella sono per l'asl and air
gear presti la porta è chiusa bene
ragazzi sta a casa è fatto abbastanza
bene diciamo bello sto bambino c'è
proprio l'espressione della felicità
proprio è vero lo slider dopotutto
e si è simbolo di felicità e tutto il
resto questo è il cane dello slider
abbiamo tutta la famiglia al completo
ragazzi devo anche tener conto che ha un
tocco esotico lowes lander che che non
indifferente diciamo vabbè ma anche il
dj a tempo libero ragazzi perché
ovviamente lo slider è famoso anche per
i suoi pezzi ha fatto un dual con
skrillex l'ultima volta che ho sentito
un suo pezzo orecchiabile però non sono
qui per questo diciamo veniamo di uscire
il prima possibile cos'è sta roba
e questo è il nuovo album dello
stendardo sciamava
non c'è niente da fare lo studio dello
slang era inutile andiamo lì con
perfetto permesso o sentito qualcosa
scricchiolare non mi è piaciuto io entro
prima va dentro perché non mi rassicura
tutto il resto
ok camino
cos'è cos'è sta roba alle lancette a
questa è una lancetta dell'orologio
allora si vede ragazzi che devo
raccogliere le lancette non l'avevo
capito e portarla all orologio 18 poi
non negare che cosa possa succedere
presumo che si apra come volendone oggi
altri due però vabbè una lancetta cielo
ragazzi devo trovare l'altra
va bene finché non appare nessuno io
sono tranquillo allora questo dipinto è
ancora fantastico ok perfetto diamo di
qua che diavolo era quel suono non ho
idea perchè non ho sentito niente a
parte questo c'è la bibbia con una
candela fantastico chalon scrigno che
tipo quello di skyrim è va bene e c'è
l'ultima lancetta ragazzi l'ho trovata
ok ok si è rotto qualcosa si è rotto
qualcosa non svenderà rotto un vetro uno
specchio sette anni di sfiga tanto fra
cazzi tuoi
io andrei di sotto perché devo mettere
le lancette però non sono per niente
tranquillo diciamo perché ho sentito dei
rumori di software vabbè allora
lasciatemi novinar e metto le lancette
si apre l'orologio dentro si trova la
chiave per quella portali sono un
veggente ragazzi
vediamo
ragazzi vi faccio io sti giochi
praticamente mai edward hall ritmi isaia
ma perché non mi fate finito di leggere
vabbè comunque praticamente si sente
come un drogato perché possa venderlo
segue simi sentire anche io più meno
così ma che bel posto ragazzi
poi mi spiegate perchè io sono dovuto
scendere qui sotto l'ho capito
non ho capito perché devo andare in
posti sempre più tenebrosi dato che c'è
un uso render che mi segue ma noi ci
andiamo lo stesso sono nelle fogne dello
slider ragazzi spero che non si sia dato
da fare al cesso di recente perché non
sarebbe gradevole cosa qua a si dà anche
da fare con l'alcol
cosa c'è scritto buon a me non me ne
frega niente bagno avanti cesta porta
qui un martello che ragazzi il martello
di thor c'è anche is l'under woods e
questa volta è bello grosso di swype
adesso mi i ragazzi possa aprirla
adesso che nella scorsa puntata non sono
riuscito ad aprirla perché era chiusa
perfetto allora dobbiamo uscire
dobbiamo uscire tasto posto ok è
accaduto qualcosa
non è rassicurante sinistra a destra oa
sinistra cos'è questa una batteria
sì ma la torcia non mi si accende da un
pezzo
poi forse non si accende imposti
illuminati non non c'è nessuno stai
tranquillo che è successo si è vista un
interferenza ma non ce lo slider a era
giusto per farmi prendere un corpo
grazie come se non avesse abbastanza ok
ragazzi progressi salvati
devo riuscire a trovare di nuovo la
portano a sfondare col martello via e
non ci riuscirò all'osso già ci devo
riuscire a trovarla prima che non
rendermi prenda e sarà veramente
un'impresa
cos'è qua matthew mansion mi pare che
fosse da questa parte non vorrei
sbagliarmi però questo qui se camminasse
più veloce mi farebbe un favore forse
forse era questa no non era questo pero
reach tommy hill si era questa apri apri
apri a fiati che si nun ce lo slider
fortunatamente no perché il martello lo
lasci a terra minchia il grosso come la
tua faccia potrebbe sfondare il cranio
allo slider ma non facciamo finta di
niente ho aperto qualcosa devo devo fare
in fretta prima che appaia quel
disgraziato che di sicuro non verrà
farmi le feste ecco diciamo questo non
smoking
non penso che lo slider fumi però vabbè
vado non so dove devo andare a gara
forse cuocerci aver causato un aprire no
c'è qualcosa qui in a bottle andiamo giù
perfetto andare nei sotterranei sempre
la cosa migliore da fare nei giochi
horror perfetto ragazzi ci siamo
progressi salvati lo svenderà ancora non
si è visto fortunatamente siamo già tipo
a più di cinque minuti quindi meglio
così
ho bisogno della benzina per far
funzionare il generatore ragazzi mi
piace mi piace veramente tanto questo
questo slider qui perché è un videogame
horror nella quale devi fare anche delle
cose ma non è troppo da diciamo
strizzarsi del cervello per continuare
tipo penombra le cose sono abbastanza
immediate
elettrica all'occhio don't work è ok
devo devo trovare la benzina per poi
aprire la porta perfetto e la benzina
dove sarà in fondo
[Musica]
intanto sente i barattoli che cadono le
pentole tutto il resto c'è una sega che
non la puoi prendere perché non si sa
mai che tu debba difendersi non ti
difendere la gente fa che sia lui a
ucciderti non provare a difenderti no
perfetto trovato a benzina ragazzi un
cacciavite norme che anna che questo
brand per difendermi
torniamo indietro perfetto ok ok cos'è a
quella scritta non è piaciuta però non
era nulla di pericoloso acqua si fa
ancora più a fondo ragazzi però è tutto
chiuso quindi non ha senso bene
generatore questo qui perfetto vai
ci siamo
è partito quindi dovrei dovrei riuscire
ad aprire la porta che prima era chiusa
questa qui perfetto ragazzi o molto più
tranquillo mi piace batterie the
marshals where the hell is allora som il
che che è successo this means to go back
to the forest ma devo trovare una chiave
che si trovano in una casa
ok la porta è chiusa però devo trovare
quella chiave per poi tornare qui ad
aprire quella porta perfetto allora dove
la chiave cassetti si apre ogni tanto no
perfetto allora la caverna l'ho vista
prima al parco lo non l'ho visto ancora
so mi ci siamo dentro la chiave si trova
in calma in casa ci sono andato prima
credo ma la casa è che casa eh va beh
noi seguiamo il tragitto allora esco da
qui vado a sinistra poi di nuovo la
prima a sinistra perché non mettono
tomtom lander sarebbe più utile comunque
sinistra la prima a sinistra poi di
nuovo a sinistra e poi a destra che
sinistra sinistra a destra
ok che cazzo è successo che bastardi
gli sviluppatori visto gioco so proprio
stronzi ragazzi telo me lo fanno apposta
lo fanno apposta c'è non è successo per
caso perché in genere lo slider spa una
per caso ma questo l'hanno fatto apposta
ci scommetto quello che volete
sì cosa i fiumi ragazzi però dai non
possono fare cose così dai non assenza
ed a [ __ ]
ok usciamo di come si esce via prima a
sinistra subito goda mehrkens il noise
in my head
non importa va e va a sinistra sinistra
sinistra smettila di camminare come un
idiota vai perché ai ragazzi la prima a
sinistra l'abbiamo presa tutto dritto
vabbè dai camminiamo tanto non c'è
nessuno che ci sta dietro
no non c'è nessuna effettivamente che ci
sta dietro per ora a sinistra di nuovo
ok vedo le interferenze
ok no non mi sono perso destra adesso
deve essere ad essere ad essere adesso
ci dovrebbe essere la casa aiuto ma non
ce la farò mai ragazzi non ce la farò
mai è impossibile è troppo veloce ciò il
personaggio non so se è andato troppo
dal mcdonald ha mangiato troppi panini
un obeso che non riesce a correre ma non
corre ok [ __ ] non si ha neanche
visto fatto talmente in fretta che non
sei neanche apparso però ragazzi il
personaggio non può camminare non ha
senso adesso non sto correndo proprio ce
la faccio piccoli scattini perché se non
muore veramente una cosa oscena guarda è
già stanco c'era veramente fai un po di
esercizio fisico per la madonna
ok ok ragazzi ok non c'e rose lander per
ora non c'è prima a sinistra c'è un
interferenza però
prima destra ok vai vai vai
no no no ho sbagliato strada forse porca
[ __ ] o sbagliato era era era l'altro
sinistra perfetto ragazzi non ho memoria
aveva proprio un deficiente a livelli
assurdi
sarà mica questo no o sì sì forse era
quel che è culo sarà salva salva salva
salva sala salva salvati prego salva no
non lo salverà partito sarebbero partito
salvo la partita no perché si è fermato
qui si è chiuso windows mi si è chiuso
windows
mi si era mi si è aperta una cosa una
finestra a caso di windows e non mi
faceva correre non ha senso ragazzi non
chiudi sta roba ma che cazzo me ne frega
dei tasti permanenti ragazzi non ce la
farò mai è impossibile tra l'altro
perché questo sgabello è una spugna o un
biscotto al cioccolato vabbè ma chi se
ne frega ragazzi che è impossibile non
corre il personaggio non corre
facciamo così ci provo l'ultima volta se
non ci riesco io finisco qui l'episodio
ci provo
la volta ancora dopo dai tagli o finché
non ci riuscirò poi nel prossimo
episodio perché se no
passiamo tutto il tempo a fare sta parte
che è impossibile vabbè dai tre due uno
via [ __ ] stronzo
ok sanya un perfect dai adesso cammino
non corrono e anche più perché tanto ci
ho perso le speranze ma si spengono la
torcia mi raggiunge non è come direi che
si spengono mi prende no secondo me
quindi se rendere peggio se spegni ti
arriva davanti i propri fisso quindi sto
camminando bene continua a camminare
dato non affatica non compare non vedo
interferenza e continua a camminare
perfetto perfetto perfetto andiamo
ragazzi ho tagliato proprio di brutto da
dalle
foreste fitte perché tanto non c'è mica
scritto che devo seguire una strada
fissa mi sono perso fantastico non era
qui era un po più in là credo da qualche
parte perfetto ragazzi mi sono perso
sono un genio ma neanche a seguire le
indicazioni come ho fatto a trovarlo
prima che ai porca [ __ ] niente
ragazzi capaci
ok direi che chiudo qui perché è
veramente impossibile il prossimo
episodio partirò già subito quando
riuscirò a farcela tagliero direttamente
al pezzo perché non posso continuare a
fare tentativi a caso quindi se volete
scoprire che cosa c'è dietro quella
porta
lasciatemi piace il video un commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook che
lascia sempre in descrizione in ogni mio
video niente se non siete ancora i siti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo prossimo video
belle ragazze ragazzi soltanto una cosa
una premessa di fine video è uscito il
primo episodio il primissimo episodio
della coop tra me ed idolo trovate in
descrizione il link che porta al suo
canale mi raccomando iscrivetevi al
canali di dido perché questa coop sarà
fantastica lo vedrete primi episodi lo
trovate qui sotto in descrizione
e niente in teoria dovrei dedicarci un
blog ogni volta che faccio uscire un
episodio ogni volta che di lo fa uscire
un episodio sul suo canale soltanto che
non l'ho fatto per il semplice motivo
che il blog l'ho fatto uscire per gli
mette due giorni fa e far uscire un
secondo blog in procede due blog in due
giorni sarebbe una cosa un po strana
quindi ne approfitto per dire vero alla
fine del video ragazzi cliccate sul link
in descrizione per andare a vedere il
primo episodio della coop tra me e di do
il prossimo ricordo sera sul mio canale
quello dopo ancora sarà su quello di
lido e questa volta farò lo dirò in un
blog
quindi niente andato ad iscrivervi e
buona visione bella ragazzi